paul wenn du auf diesem tag schaut was
ist dir ganz besonders im kopf geblieben
thomas unabhängig von diesem tag muss
man sagen dass es gerade eben wieder
luft sie reden gegeben hat hier in kiew
und wir haben explosionen gehört die in
der nähe des zentrums stattgefunden
haben relativ nahe so nah kann man sagen
wie vielleicht in den letzten tagen nie
hier auch an dem ort wo wir sind und das
kann bedeuten muss es nicht aber dass
das ganze heute eine unruhige nacht wird
für kiew davon waren ohnehin viele
beobachter ausgegangen also in den
vergangenen zwei stunden zweimal
sirenenalarm in kiew und an anschläge
einschläge explosionen relativ nahe am
zentrum wir werden noch recherchieren
müssen was dort genau passiert ist dass
in diesem moment live hier paul wie
empfindest du diese ganze hilfswelle
diese solidaritätswelle die jetzt rollt
auch aus deutschland heraus
glockengeläute wurde angekündigt in ganz
deutschland für 20 uhr es zu sammeln
menschen spenden geld spenden wir auch
sachspenden ja bekommen die menschen
dass in der ukraine in kiew bei dem mit
die menschen sorgen sich darum ob sie am
nächsten tag noch am leben sind ob jetzt
in deutschland spenden gesammelt werden
ist dann eher ein zweites oder drittes
thema
das ist etwas was hier im alltag keine
rolle spielt was aber wahnsinnig wichtig
ist die menschen brauchen unterstützung
spendenhilfe gerade die kinder die
frauen all das muss sein aber wenn du
hier mit den menschen spricht dann reden
sie über die angriffe über die raketen
über das was am fernsehturm passiert ist
über das was in kharkiv passiert ist
über die waffen die russland einsetzt
diese grausamen waffen die belege dafür
dass es streumunition war und die
menschen hier in kiew die haben sorge
dass heute nach genau das auch auf sie
nieder regnet dass diese feuerball auch
in ihre stadt kommt pauli heute gab es
eine sondersitzung nach drei tagen zu
ende gegangen der eine un
vollversammlung in new yorker
überwältigen der abstimmung
überwältigende verurteilung dieses
krieges und russlands von fast 200
nationen die dort vertreten waren haben
nur 4 dagegen gestimmt gegen diese
resolution die verabschiedet wurde das
sind russland natürlich selber und unter
anderem noch syrien und nordkorea das
sind also die länder in deren
gesellschaft sich russland jetzt
befindet
thomas und jemand hat geschrieben bei
twitter war es glaube ich wenn venezuela
und iran nicht mehr auf deiner seite
stehen dann bist du wohl wirklich ein
kriegsverbrecher denn das sind ja seine
verbündeten gewesen in den vergangenen
jahren insbesondere venezuela mit dem
sozialistischen führer maduro also
russland ist völlig isoliert
richtig aber was bedeutet dass und es
sieht nicht danach aus als würde putin
sich in irgendeiner form diesen
sanktionsdruck ergeben ganz im gegenteil
es sieht danach aus dass er weitermacht
härter reingeht noch mehr waffen hier
rein schmeißt die sanktionen sind
richtig und wichtig und die müssen seien
absolut und es sieht die ukraine so die
ukrainischen politiker sagen wir
brauchen eigentlich noch mehr noch
schärfer also für die ukraine kann es
gar nicht hart genug sollten zusagen
über das business abbrechen deutsche
firmen gar nichts mehr mit russland
machen es müssen diese regierung den
druck verspüren dass das ein ende hat
die große frage wird sein was uns
anderer wie lang hält kiew wie lange
kann man verhindern dass es den kessel
und kiew gibt dass man sozusagen hier
immer noch weitere wege der versorgung
hat wenn man kiew einkreist dann wird
sehen wie lange noch war natürlich auch
deine frage an die klitschko-brüder die
duh heute nochmal treffen durfte ja was
war ihre botschaft was ist geblieben von
diesem emotionalen interview
das ist jeder minute los gehen kann dass
sie hilfe brauchen das ohne die hilfe
sie sterben werden dass sie allein sind
nicht die beiden auf sich bezogen
sondern die ukraine und dass die welt
die ukraine unterstützen muss dennoch
muss man sagen ja das passiert teilweise
und das passiert richtig und endlich ist
diese solidarität da die schon viel viel
früher hätte da sein müssen auch in
anderen situationen geschenkt aber
es bleibt bei der
wahrheit dass die ukraine kein bündnis
hat die ukraine ist nicht teil der nato
die ukraine hat keine staaten die ihn
militärisch beispringen werden und
dieser dieser resistenz dieser
widerstand der hier stattfindet ist
beeindruckend zu sehen und der
patriotismus ist beeindruckend zu sehen
aber wenn wladimir putin so weiter macht
wenn er wirklich gewählt ist hier alles
darauf zu werfen was er an waffen hat
dann muss man realistisch sagen stehen
schlimme wochen schlimme monate und am
ende ist es kaum denkbar dass das
ukrainische militär das dann wirklich
abwehren kann wir werden sehen zu was
putin bereit ist und schauen wie es
weiter geht heute nach